[음악]
제가 부산지사를 이제 설립하려고
준비 중에 있는데 그 제가 저번주에
부산도 내려갔어요 내려가서 그 사무실
자리도 좀 받고 제가 간단하게 면접도
좀 봤습니다 그래서
생각보다 이메일도 되게 많이 와서
놀랬었고 부산을 가서 느낀 점은
서울이랑 조금 다르게 또 한번 생각해
봐야겠구나
완전
새로 시작해야겠다라는 생각을 좀 하게
됐고 그리고 많은 분들을 만나면서
하나같이 말씀해주셨던게 부산은
학연이나 이런게 있다 아무래도
인맥이나 이런게 커가지고 좀
들어오기 쉽지 않을 것 같다라는
얘기를 좀 많이 듣긴 했지만 저는
오히려 더 기회가 있을 것 같습니다
어떻게 보면 아직까지는 그렇게
변화가 안 된 거 같거든요
뭔가 더 진입하기에는 되게 매력적인
곳이다라고 생각을 하게 됐고
서면에 있는 뭐 빌딩들뿐만 아니라 그
다음에 이제 해 밑에 있는 빌딩 그
두 지역 위주로 좀
빌딩을 많이 데이터를 쌓을 거고
최근에 뜨고 있는 지역들을 좀 알게
됐어요 부산 내에서도 그래서 여기도
한번 저희가
서울로 치자면 예전에 뭐 성수동 한
것처럼 아니면 무슨 격리단길 뭐
예전에 그런 막 생겨나는
곳 한 것처럼 그쪽도 좀 데이터를
많이
쌓으려고 좀 노력을 할 예정입니다
그래서 좀 되게
재밌는 시장 같아요 그거뿐만 아니라
해운대에 주택들도 좀 많이 다룰
예정이에요 그래서 뭐 lct라던지
아니면 마린시티 내에 있는 그런
주택들도 좀 다뤄볼까 생각을 하고
있습니다 만약에 제가 설립을 하게
된다면 뭐 서울에서 사용하고 있는
그런 시스템들을 다 접목시킬
예정이에요 그래서 뭐 예를 들면 저희
이제 신입 직원
매뉴얼이라든지 그리고 뭐 어떤
시스템을 가지고
운영하는 건지 그런 것도 다 이제
서울에 맞게 운영할 예정이고
프로그램도 저희가 이미 다 개발을
해놨거든요
빌딩 이제 프로그램이라든지 저희가
고급 주택 프로그램도 개발이 돼 있기
때문에 부산 것만 이제 업데이트 하면
되거든요 물론
데이터는 없지만 부산 데이터를 쌓는데
시간이 좀 걸리긴 하겠지만 이게
쌓이면 제가 봤을 때는
그래도 되게 경쟁력이 있을 것 같아요
그래서 고객분들이 왔을 때도
매물을 브리핑 받는 거라든지 아니면
출력물이라든지 아니면 검색하는
거라든지 이런 프로그램은 저희가 뭐
기존에 잘 개발을 해왔어 가지고 좀
부산에 적용만 하고 이게 데이터만
쌓이면 부산 내에서 경쟁력 있는
법인이 되지 않을까네 이렇게 생각을
하고 더 나아가서 부산에 있는 건물을
저희가 설계하거나 그리고 저희가 건설
면허증도 있잖아요 그래서 건물을 이제
신축이나 리모델링까지 같이 할 수
있기 때문에 되게 좀 긍정적으로 보고
있고 설립하려고 하고 있습니다 그래서
빠르면 2월달 내에 이제 설립을 할
거 같고 그때 이제 아무래도
함께할 분들이 좀 많이 필요하긴 한데
일단 부산 지사를 운영하실 분은 제가
어느 정도 선별은 했긴 했어요 그래서
그분이 아마 하실 것 같고 저희 그
같이 하실 그 공인중개사분들이 좀
많이 필요하긴 합니다
혹시 부산지사에 관심있는 공인중개사
분들이 계신다면은
매일 주소를 제가 좀 써 놓을테니까
여기로
간단한 이력서를 좀 보내주시면 저희가
검토를 한 다음에 같이 이렇게 좀
키워 나갈 수 있을 것 같습니다 뭐
처음에는 물론 시간도 좀 많이 걸리고
좀 힘들 수도 있겠지만 이게 좀
데이터가 많이 쌓이고
달하는 중개사 분들이 많이 모이기
시작한다면 저는 되게 경쟁력이 있을
것 같습니다 그럴 것 같으니까 사실
서울에 있는 지금 중계
사무소나 중개법인 중에서도 부산에
많이 진출
했을 것 같아요 근데
시도를 안 했거나 아니면은 안 된
이유가 있기는 할 거 같거든요 저는
어찌됐든
그래도 도전해보면 좋다라 물론 이제
해서 안 될 수도 있습니다 근데 일단
해보고 좀 시행착오를 저도 겪어야 될
것 같아요 그리고 제가 자리 잡기
전까지는 제가 관여를 많이 할
생각입니다
매주 정기적으로 가가지고 좀
시스템이라든지 마케팅 이라든지 어떻게
돌아가고 있는지 교육 같은 거라든지
이런 거를 되게 많이 신경 써서 할
예정이고 여기서 만약에 저희가 좀
자리를 잡게 된다면
다른 지역도 한번 또 생각해 볼 수
있을 것 같아요
관심 있으시거나 하신 분들은
언제든지메일로 보내주시고 저는 오히려
지금같이 좀 그 상황이 안 좋을 때
하는게 더 어떻게 보면 매력이
있다라고 생각하거든요 저희 bsn이
제일 잘 하고 있는 방식대로 한번
적용을 해볼 생각이에요 따로 이제
영상도 찍을 예정이고
혹시 뭐 상담이 필요하신 분 계시면
갈 때마다 상담을 할 생각이거든요
그리고 면접도 볼 예정이고
bsm 부산지사 관심 있으신 분들은
지금메일로 보내주시면 개별
연락을 드릴 예정이고 2월 달까지만
모집을 해서 같이 좀
키워 나갈 예정입니다 그래서 좀 많은
분들이 지원해 주셨으면 좋겠고 지금
뭐 공인중개사 지금 시장 상황이라든지
이런게 좋진 않은데 오히려 이럴
때일수록
기본을 좀
튼튼하게 해가지고 나중에 좋은 장이
왔을 때 그때 이제 확
날아올라야 되거든요 그래서
그러기에는 저는 너무 좋은 시기라고
생각합니다 그래서
bsm 부산지사와 함께 하실
공인중개사 여러분들은
꼭
연락 주세요 그래서 오늘 영상은
여기까지 하겠습니다
감사합니다